what I'm doing here speak a little truth
people lose their mind for two years in
a row not a single actor of color has
received an Oscar nomination but is it
really just the Oscars that are still so
white or does Hollywood have a larger
problem one of the only non-white
nominees for a major category this year
is Mexican director Alejandro Gonzalez
Inarritu for the revenant
the beauty of United States and the
power of United States its bill is
founded in that mix raised country and
that it is not represented in the screen
this is especially true for Latino
characters an analysis of 100 films from
2014 found that Latinos were given less
than 5% of speaking roles even though
they account for 17 percent of the u.s.
population and still the experts
sometimes mix up the most recognizable
latina actresses hi I'm Eva Longoria not
Ava Mendes and hi I'm America Ferrera
not Gina Rodriguez yes
and neither neither one of us or rosario
Dawson that joke was in response to the
Golden Globes mistakenly identifying
America Ferrera as Gina Rodriguez on its
official Twitter account all three by
the way have won or been nominated for
Golden Globes when he won the Golden
Globe for Best Actor Leonardo DiCaprio
devoted his speech to indigenous
populations around the world but he
wasn't the first
when Marlon Brando won an Oscar for the
Godfather he asked Native American
actress sushi in Littlefeather to give a
speech on his behalf he were very
regretful 'i cannot accept this very
generous award and the reasons for this
being are the treatment of american
indians today by the film industry more
than 40 years later we have Native
American characters like beavers breath
and no bra and Adam Sandler's movie the
ridiculous six the movie was so
offensive that several Native American
actors walked off set in protest and the
cultural consultant even quit Netflix
which produced the movie said it was a
satire but for actors regularly typecast
by their race it's not so funny as an
actor of color I do feel like there's a
void or a shortage of material that is a
high level that is challenging that
really deals with human experience in
January Nate Parker landed the biggest
deal ever made at the Sundance Film
Festival for The Birth of a Nation a
movie about a slave uprising he spent
seven years making the film acting in it
and even used his own money to get it
done because for many actors the choice
is usually between playing a stereotype
or nothing at all of the 100 top
grossing films of 2014 17 did not have a
single black character with a speaking
rule 40 of those movies didn't have a
single Asian character with lines TV is
better but not by much very few
television comedies or dramas cast
minorities as lead characters and we
know diversity does
all straight out of Compton made over
200 million dollars at the box office an
empire is the second most viewed TV show
for the coveted 18 to 49 demographic one
way to increase the roles available for
minority actors is to give more
opportunities to directors of color
nearly 83 percent of movie features
released in 2013 and 2014 were directed
by Caucasian males compared to just 11
percent by minority directors it's even
worse if you're a minority and female
they only direct around 1% of feature
films and 3% of TV shows director Spike
Lee has argued this won't change until
studios have more executives of color
willing to give filmmakers a green light
the Academy has pledged to double the
number of women and minority members but
will that be enough to make Hollywood
look like the rest of America
[Music]
you